[Música]
[Aplausos]
olá boa tarde uma energia linda aqui
obrigada por não ter equipe não vire um
carinho
não sou pessoa de ter grande memória
trabalho com dentro da indústria
criativa e já vão passar a explicar o
que é isso tem que ser criativa passado
muitos já trabalham nos e criativa e
funcionam quando defendi mas acima de
tudo das coisas que mais me apaixona
vira são as crianças só é natureza eu
viver nas áreas em que opera
dependemos do talento e da criatividade
para conseguirmos transformado em
produtos ou em algum serviço é o américa
está intermitentemente está em
tratamento da tecnologia é está no nosso
presença de todos a falar outra vez de
indústria criativa
hoje em dia o docente ea criança estão
ligados automaticamente com essa
indústria se conseguem reconhecer
conseguem se relacionar identificado
as vagas nos vários setores da indústria
criativa
queria que virá é matéria prima desse
setor e como é que este setor
o setor da indústria criativa
trabalhando a criatividade basicamente à
cultura o património material e
imaterial
os museus loja visual criações culturais
e funcionais ao espetáculo teatral dança
às pressões culturais das mais variadas
desde nossa cultura popular até às artes
digitais de uma forma simples podemos
dizer que se trata de um setor que reúne
as atividades que tem na sua essência
mas a aí você não precisa da crise virá
a simplicidade do homem de hoje de criar
sempre algo novo deverá um novo o homem
tá nessa busca em santos já cerca de 50
anos e inês e com neste milênio ainda
mais o fenômeno globalização é outro dos
influentes na nossa política da nossa
criatividade é porque ele que nós
conseguimos medir e ver a capacidade de
como as várias vários países os vários
grupos conseguem lidar com as várias
transformações da nossa economia mundial
mas na verdade o conhecimento sul queria
virar ficou facilitado quando o ser
humano entendeu mais sobre o cérebro
humano é perder e algumas formas alguns
preconceitos que irão a consciência
coletiva a temos aquela fase da
identificação das várias áreas da
economia à consciência coletiva e eu
queria ter virado não acontece por acaso
acontecesse um estímulo à crítica de
criatividade nas conosco mas muito
facilmente pode ser derrubada com a
escola onde a escola onde as
aprendizagens onde os preconceitos com
muitas vezes nós não estão embutindo o
que nós temos que encarar
tenho passado aqui o caso do site nós e
nós conseguirmos eu conseguisse atuar
entretanto nesta fase
assim sendo resumindo o carinho que eles
têm com a linha criativa e para não
perder aqui no tema a economia criativa
tem a sua origem habilidade e
criatividade são individuais e
empresários de forma estratégica tem
potencial para a criação dos rendimentos
e empregos e por meio de geração da
exploração da propriedade intelectual
isso é um dos temas que está muito nas
agendas do da economia criativa à
propriedade intelectual mas não é por aí
que vai ser um bom caminho e vamos ver
vamos passar por uma etapa e tem mais a
ver com a criança e também por quebrar
um carinho os médios filas uma das quais
é esta que a criatividade não é magia
criatividade no nós em alguém
privilegiado e que de repente tem uma
ideia só essa sua primeira chance na
criatividade nós com qualquer um nós
nunca tiro mas é isso tem que ficar a
o segundo aspecto é que todos temos
potencial criativo
independentemente da nossa personalidade
independentemente dos nossos gols em
impedimento nosso bairro alto diz ter
esse potencial criativo em nós
o terceiro aspecto é que a criatividade
não mistério isso porque não é eo punho
em uma analogia de uma imagem que é o
buraco negro não é nada temos que buscar
no fundo da caverna que tal que é
transcendental a ser humano
o criativo normalmente partilha é um
sonho que está interessado nessa nesta
partilha com os seus passos
é daí que também consegue encontrar as
soluções para os desafios
outro aspecto é que a criatividade não é
loucura era uma espécie ficou muito
tempo na cabeça de sua agenda cidadã
entre o argumento da verdade é que a
loucura nem sequer uma derrota mas quero
ajudar a criatividade mas acreditem na
frente estudada por vários várias áreas
recebendo
e em várias etapas eu conseguir aqui
cinco etapas que tenha a ver com o
desenvolvimento dessa pesquisa sobre a
criatividade a primeira etapa
situa se nos anos 50 foi uma geração que
na verdade não conseguiu desenvolver um
sentido de criatividade ou ficou nó nos
tornou um assunto
colom e ela mas nessa altura ele ficava
secret virada com uma capacidade de
fazer algo diferente
na segunda etapa a que ele teve na tua
associada à assunção a solução criativa
de problemas
este já dentro de uma ótica da empresa
quando você perceber que um criativo é
que se estava a falar dentro da empresa
na terceira geração na terceira fase já
se pensa que virá também neste corpo
nesta componente do negócio mas assim
que o criativo está em confronto com um
problema e não vai pensar primeiro na
sua capacidade de só ter o formato
depois apresentar uma solução nos anos
90 muranos a criatividade com sua
circunstância colombo culinários como
uma atitude e nós temos a terceira
geração
gastamos na quinta na quinta geração da
silva e nesta quinta geração nós estamos
numa fase em que nós chamamos a
criatividade ou as áreas de check in mas
acredita em uma economia criativa e mais
uma vez pega assinado liberdade
individual nos tamanhos individuais e
empresários de tal forma estratégica
conseguimos fazer pressão de rendimento
e de empregos e cada vez mais a nova
geração de criativos que agora já soma e
com profissionais também participam da
produção de políticas públicas e ações
de interesse social empregos de
qualidade
mas o que a escola tem a ver com
economia criativa porque escutava o
bonequinho eu venho aqui falar na
verdade a escola como nós nos lembramos
ela nasce numa altura em que não está
associada à criatividade na verdade e eu
nós numa altura se você pensar bem no
edifício escolar é que surgem os
hospitais as prisões
o exército é um caso condenado o acerto
ainda fala na essência da palavra amor à
ecologia da palavra grega escola quer
dizer lazer
o tempo livre e eu queria de verdade tem
tudo a ver com a escola porque é parte
da organização humana que está
vocacionada para capacitar as pessoas
para os tais desafios nesta sessão da
palavra escola tenha cinco em
consideração um homem era acusado e hoje
em dia nós sabemos que a capacidade 1 o
proveito da escola para uns tirar dessa
sociedade hierarquizada a escola podem
escolher a atingir o feito do dna que
está estipulada socialmente e nos dias
de hoje nós passaram cerca de 10 a 18
anos dentro de uma escola na escola
então ajudar a selecionar a informação
da escola a mãe
a criatividade da criança estimulá la
isto porque a escola tem esta
responsabilidade de capacitar as pessoas
para os desafios sociais
no entanto sabe que se ressalvar que a
escola também deve respeitar a cultura
no ângulo a cultura do estado da cultura
é nosso desenvolvimento de base
sabemos carro a educação ea escola são
responsáveis pelo desenvolvimento das
competências criativas e não foi dos
números perspectiva multidisciplinar e
interdisciplinar também estamos a falar
do técnico e científico
estamos a falar do cultural e criativo e
de negócios para promover a educação
para a economia criativa é fundamental a
introdução de conteúdos vinculados às
competências criativas em programas
educacionais que sejam atualizados hoje
em dia ainda é moda tecnologia alguma
lacuna dentro dos maias da indústria
criativa na área da formação
o desenvolvimento da criatividade e
estudantes passa também pela produção do
saber e fazer isto destrói três finais
eu gostava que nós vemos agora um vídeo
e shows lotados com a qual emergiu que
do do artista contemporâneo ao ano eo
zagueiro miranda pdf romã da marcha e
também hebe é o bacana é paciência
o motorista anã neta kelly sul
o mac em dólares a favor da mãe olhou
pra mim e falou mas agora mudou
completamente a minha voz está assim
mais estranho este vídeo é do artista
contemporâneo da ilha de luanda hélder
câmara e representa importante
exatamente esse imaginário infantil
agregado é isso a criatividade da
própria crise as próprias crianças que
tudo pense imaginam como motorista do
peixe já se imaginam como um cliente
muito exigente e aí nós podemos perceber
que a criatividade das crianças é
incomensurável é uma coisa que não tem
medida
e aí que nós pensamos que temos que
atacar mesmo ano nessas cidades
temos que estimular as crianças para as
mais vários tipos de ofícios vários
tipos de materiais que fazem
desenvolvimento desenvolver esse
pensamento criativo entre o santo como é
que a criatividade nas dentro de cada um
de nós por meio dos mais variados
estilos
mais interessante ainda é perceber muito
cedo
a criatividade é implementada por nós
dessas maneiras na praia sem nada e o
firman que essa parte do mito de que
esta fase da vida é fácil da maior
experimentação possível e como é que nós
implementamos a nossa criatividade com a
brincar e eu vou um carinho entrar
nestas nesta conversa do brincar porque
primeiro porque é um direito da criança
brincar depois porque é na brincadeira
que ela vá experimentando vários papéis
sociais em que ela vai expressando
também as suas opiniões é parte da
brincadeira também que muitas vezes
crianças manifestam alguns desagrados
que acontecem na vida de áden e as
crianças muitos vídeos montanha o tempo
ou espaço de brincadeira porque estão
simplesmente agarrados à tablets e
telemóveis é creche
nós já rodamos um carinho da educação
presti veículos da economia criativa na
maior pesquisa jamais feita sobre a
educação
comprovou-se que ainda existe mais 118
influenciador para a lenda da
comunicação social dos media do
professor da escola existe este tal
influenciador máximo que é um professor
noel e sabemos também que esse professor
está a acompanhar uma escola e mudança
mas que a mudança de escolar está a ser
um processo muito lento
sabemos que um bom professor podem
impactar a vida toda do ser humano
um bom professor é que nesta conta
corresponde a 11 de maio mais de
aprendizagens ao contrário de que o mau
professor representa um aluno aprender
lutado e porque eu pego porque o pai
nesta nesta nesta conta matemática
sintoma a um ansiado cada vez mais o
professor sair também dentro da escola
não só para buscar ajuda aos seus
conteúdos como também buscar outras
fontes de aprendizagem outros setores
que podem conciliar essa essas mesmas
aprendizagens falta de visitas estudos a
museus galerias arquivos a bibliotecas
faltam banho de visitas até a setur de
funcionalidade da empresa a empresas
o processo tem feito dentro da escola
tem que apoiar também de outros
organismos
e quando falo dos organismos falta mãe
de noemi disse que desenvolvem trabalhos
na área de educação falta bairro
associações que trabalham exatamente na
intervenção social e com as crianças
e aí com
nós temos que dar a pensar em quantos
professores é nossa nós aprendemos na
vida da professora este nem sempre o
nosso professor primário até o poço
significou mais dentro da nossa da nossa
escola
a verdade é que nós podemos aprender com
vários mais hoje em dia nós aprendemos
com tutoriais aprendemos com grohl modo
as condições que nós admiramos e
gostamos de alguma maneira elas nos
inspiraram e aprendemos com os nossos
amigos
aprendemos com um é tóxico
aprendemos com outro tipo de outros
tipos de saber mas entretanto contou
assim uma empresa aqui o papel e quer
deixar preso ao papel
gostava de falar mais uma vez sobre o
que a criança quando ela contacto com
este veículo não é da economia criativa
e quando eu acabo fria que cada vez mais
toda errada voltar button telemóvel
na verdade o duelo já está a demonstrar
que ela é um consumidor e não só é um
consumidor como ela também já domina
estas áreas ea nintendo que a economia
criativa que edson que é uma e criativo
vamos dar um exemplo crianças pequenas
uma câmera de vídeo elas conseguem
simular um filme fazer um filme
aí elas voltaram a fazer o quê voltará a
história trilhões de organização de
pré-produção na produção e às vezes a
pós-produção se conseguirem se ter um
computador ipos editarem as imagens
filmadas a criança além disso às vezes
tem que fazer escolhas porque é muito
sugestivo nada por pelo maio
imagine um dia estava a saída de uma de
uma escola de um projeto ea uma criança
que falou bisavó olha vou ser animador
ea volta da concessão dela
preconceituosa pessoa animador
afinal o peixe palhaço
a criança na verdade o que ela queria
dizer é que ela queria ser animador
digital
ela queria fazer queria trabalhar com
sede em haia e com tecnologia ela queria
fazer um step da sua vida dentro daquilo
que ela ia se carlos relaciona normal -
esta não compreendeu muitas vezes a
escola também não compreende não
encaminha e aí eu volto a falar outra
vez e aí vamos buscar os nossos
professores as nossas outras referências
muitas vezes relativamente ao ensino e à
escola também perguntam o que o que um
bom professor que o que eu faço eu sendo
mãe eu escolher um bom professor é uma
boa escola
eu enquanto mãe quando eu penso que é
uma boa escola um bom professor
op - que é uma boa escola para mim é
minha ótica eu vou analisar vários
fatores um a proximidade do local de
trabalho e da minha casa
o outro fator vão ser as condições que a
escola não vai disponibilizar os
equipamentos desportivos nas salas de
aula estou em condições
o outro será o fator do conteúdo de quem
são os professores
mas aí já é mais difícil nós
quantificarmos porquê porque a escola
como eu disse há pouco estar numa
mudança muito lenta e os preços
continuam a seguir os mesmos padrões das
velhas normas as velhas velhas
indicações e isso não quer dizer que os
professores são suas datadas eu também
sou professora mas sim cada vez mais e
acho que a minha conversa passa por aí
mais necessidade de partilhar com
pessoas que estão fora do setor só para
o setor de educação com pessoas
criativas que solucionam várias questões
nomeadamente a educação sem ser por
normas
o projeto e os que já foram definidos há
mais de 50 anos e então nessa altura eu
apelo a esta é esta a quem é formador
dentro das áreas da economia criativa é
que acha que cada vez mais impulso
dentro das próprias empresas porque a
economia criativa está em todas as
empresas e economia criativa
em vários meios economia criativa que
está fora das do negócio
a economia criativa faz parte da nossa
sociedade e um apelo a quem é também não
sofre uma dor mas influenciador que
olhem também muitas vezes com os vossos
filhos se algum dia fizerem essa escolha
de crer em seguir por uma árida da
indústria criativa de alguma maneira o
apoio e estimulem pelos bairros vários
mas porque o seu entender este maio seu
entender estes meios
espero que essa esta conversa não foi
tentei ser ano de uma maneira intuitiva
mas como coloquei isso com professora
que normalmente há sempre olhar o quadro
já leva àquela forma escrita já vem com
bateria de casa
foi difícil pra mim também eu também
participar e estar mais enfiado nicho da
criatividade na maneira de falar mais
criativamente muito obrigada
[Aplausos]